In 2009, District 9 became the surprise hit
movie of the year.
On a budget of just $30 million, the movie
went on to make $210 million at the worldwide
box office and was nominated for four Academy
Awards, including Best Motion Picture.
Although it didn't win any Oscars, District
9's breakout success was an impressive feat
for an indie sci-fi film out of South Africa
with a first-time writer/director that featured
no movie stars.
So why wasn't a sequel to District 9 ever
made?
Here's why.
A standalone story
According to District 9 mastermind Neill Blomkamp,
he wasn't even thinking about making a sequel
while writing, directing, and editing the
film.
Since Blomkamp was only planning on making
a standalone film, he didn't set up the overall
story arc was for a sequel or a franchise.
It was only after the film was edited that
Blomkamp realized there was room for a sequel,
but he still had no idea where that sequel
would go.
He also toyed around with making a prequel
instead.
Blomkamp told Hero Complex in 2010:
"I'm not so interested in aliens coming back
and blowing things up but [a prequel] might
be interesting."
Obviously that idea never left the ground
either, and it wasn't until 2015 that Blomkamp
said that he had a "really cool idea" for
a District 9 sequel.
Does that mean that a sequel is finally on
the way?
At the moment, it doesn't look likely.
Original films
In a perfect world, production on a District
9 sequel would have started shortly after
the first one was released.
However, without an idea for the sequel, Blomkamp
instead used the success of District 9 to
get another original sci-fi film into production
within months of District 9's release.
That movie was Elysium, which he worked on
until late 2012.
While shooting Elysium, Blomkamp and his wife/co-screenwriter,
Terri Tatchell, wrote the script for Chappie
in two weeks, and after Elysium wrapped, they
immediately started working on that.
Production on that movie lasted into 2014,
and it was released in theaters in February
2015.
So yeah, those movies kept Blomkamp pretty
busy post-District 9.
Blomkamp told Rolling Stone that if he were
to do the sequel properly, it would take three
years to make.
That's a big time commitment, all while the
movie that set it all off recedes into fans'
memories...
Other projects
Chappie was released in May 2015, and although
there hasn't been much news about the director
since then, Blomkamp has definitely been busy.
In April 2017, Blomkamp revealed on Twitter
that he would be making "experimental" short
films for the video game platform, Steam.
That's a big change from big-budget sci-fi
flicks, although at this point in his career
it's certainly less risky than taking a chance
on a sequel to District 9.
Blomkamp was also briefly attached to direct
a fifth entry in the Alien series, going so
far as to release tantalizing unofficial concept
art on Instagram, but unfortunately, that
project probably isn't happening.
In January 2017, Blomkamp tweeted the awful
truth: the chances of his Alien movie ever
moving forward are "slim," echoing an earlier
tweet that the movie was set aside pending
the success or failure of Alien: Covenant.
That doesn't mean that Blomkamp's blockbuster
days are over.
After all, this wouldn't be the first time
Blomkamp has bounced back after being sidelined
on a high-profile film project.
Originally, Blomkamp was picked by Peter Jackson
to direct a movie based on the Halo video
game franchise.
When Halo fell through, Jackson agreed to
produce District 9 based on Blomkamp's 2006
short film "Alive in Joberg."
In other words, the fact that Blomkamp hasn't
made a movie for several years now doesn't
mean that a District 9 sequel will never happen...although
it seems to be getting less and less likely.
Sharlto Copley is busy, too
Although he looks different at the end of
the film, Sharlto Copley is the face of District
9.
In his breakout role as the delightfully clueless
bureaucrat, the South African actor wowed
international audiences and launched his Hollywood
career.
"But I don't trust it.
I don't trust anything tha-...
Pwwwwww!"
"You alright mate?"
"Vickers, you alright?"
"Cut it!"
After Chappie, Copley's third collaboration
with Neill Blomkamp, the actor went on to
star in the Playstation series Powers and
the action thriller Free Fire.
As busy as he is, though, Copley has made
it clear that he'd gladly reprise his role
if a District 9 sequel ever materialized.
Too hard to follow up?
District 9 ended on a cliffhanger, and the
universe of the film is rich with themes and
storylines to explore.
Copley wants to do a sequel, and the movie
was a huge success for Peter Jackson's production
company.
In Hollywood, that combination usually adds
up to a guaranteed sequel.
And yet the furthest in development that the
District 9 sequel got was an 18-page treatment.
One reason for that may be because District
9 was too big of a hit.
Its commentary on social segregation, xenophobia,
and racism blended perfectly with its sci-fi
aesthetic, all of which helped make it an
overwhelming success for the first-time writer/director.
That's a hard act to follow — even when
the act you're following is your own.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love too!